this is actually this is a quote from dr
jordan peterson and and this is a prime
example of
what not to do in a relationship uh but
i i it illustrates a few points i wanted
to make
this you want something like this is
what his advice was he's given a lot of
advice about like what to look for in a
girl right
um this is the man who like it talks
about how he fell in love with his wife
when he was seven years old and
went through this sort of has been very
blue pill pretty much his entire life
but so here's what he says he says you
want someone to contend with
because you learn through that wrestling
you learn where you're an idiot and
where you
should stop being an idiot and vice
versa okay so first of all that
self-deprecation right there
it's like i'm an idiot and i need a wife
to help me save me from myself
this is the plot of every single
stupid inane you know uh
sitcom since 19 since dr huxtable right
since 1985. okay this is this is the
plot
from everybody loves raymond that's what
this is save me from myself
mommy i need you i'm an idiot i'm a man
and i need a woman to tell me that i'm
an idiot
so that's the spiritual aspect of
marriage the fact that you have to
contend with someone
under all that sort do you think that
the patriarchs of old really said i want
to contend with someone i really want a
wife to contend with
under all that sort of circumstance it's
a manner of promoting psychological or
spiritual growth
now this is where you're going to get
into so the woo-woo magical thinking
side of things because a lot of guys
when they get into like really right now
marriage as as we've been illustrating
throughout this podcast
marriage is for elite men right you have
to be if there may have you have to have
the
666 right six foot tall six pack abs
six figure income uh you've got it and
that's just
entry level right just what was myron
just saying
that's entry level that's not even elite
so
really what mayor and i'm i'm quoting
dalrock here is marriage has become for
it has become a an institution not only
of like upper middle
upper middle class people with with
college degrees but it's also
elite in the sense that you have to be
one of these guys to earn
the honor of being marriageable
of being economically attractive so that
you can get into the perfect
relationship
which is contending with a woman so she
can tell you when you're an idiot
and what what i what i want to point out
in all of this
is that when you when you see this when
you see stuff like this these are people
who are
these are old order thinkers and so guys
will say well i don't want a girl that's
uh like stupid like troy was saying i
you know i don't want to go with a phd
student but i don't necessarily want to
get with somebody who is
you know you know functionally [ __ ]
but
it's like that's the only thing because
we live in the age of emotion and it's
all
binary extreme so if she's not a [ __ ]
doctoral candidate for like astrophysics
she's this idiot uh barista who had
never finished high school
those are the only two choices first off
baristas are college grads
i i have i have really great
conversations with my wife did she ever
go to
you know to to to med school or to no
she didn't right
and we could i could still relate with
her and you know
we we have a we have have had a very
good relationship for the last 24 years
does she correct me no she doesn't
correct me if anything
you know what you want in a woman you
want a woman who has insight
who can check herself who knows when
she's wrong
and is willing to admit it because
that's why i get into it with guys on on
twitter all the time because
they'll say women never apologize and
they're right they don't
so when they do it's this rare occasion
they never give a compliment and they
never apologize
for anything because we live in an age
where women are blameless they're
sinless
they don't do anything wrong only men do
things wrong how do we know that well
since the mid 80s we've been taught that
men are either abusers
or they're ridiculous buffoons in you
know their homer simpsons
or they're rapists or potential rapists
those are the three choices you have
when you pick a man
according to popular consciousness today
in western societies
so when we say well men are flawed well
they can be flawed in those three ways
how can we make them
men you need to do better that's and if
your marriage is based
on you need to keep doing better you
need to make more you need to do this
you don't have the frame she has the
frame and she will continue to have that
frame
so long as that's what's being fed to
her and that's what you expect
from yourself because most guys when
they get into marriages
they expect to get into that marriage
and think that now it's an equal
partnership
it's equal we're even steven's right now
no
women don't want an equal they can't
look up to a man who
is their equal they want somebody who's
better than it's the patrice o'neill
thing right you want a man who's smarter
than you
bigger than you uh more violent than you
makes more money than you
uh has broader shoulders than you all
these things and you once want him to
think that
he's your equal no that's not how that
works
and that and when when you see something
like what was that
gottlieb or or jordan peterson here
they're basing
their suggestions on old order
thinking that's what this is
you